Remember that a service is where you
would put view independent logic.
At first, services seem very
similar to controllers,
both of them provide
data to an application.
A major difference is that services
are not intended for just one view.
A service is not tied to
a specific controller but
can be used by any
number of controllers.
For example, this user service has
information about the logged in user.
And account controller
could use the user service
to supply data to its template and
there's also the navigation controller
which needs the user information.
The user service can be injected into
both controllers since it's just
a source of data and functionality.
In our app we might want data from
the menu items to be displayed in other
locations.
So let's generate a service to detangle
our menu data from this specific
controller and template.
Then we'll see how we can
inject it into a controller.
We can generate a service with
the Angular generator by running yo
angular service and
providing a name for the service.
Well this should look familiar since it
starts out exactly like a controller.
We get our apps module.
Create a new service with a name.
And then provide the function.
Just like with controllers, when we call
service on the module, this name and
function are being stored
with Angular's injector.
When a controller asks for
service with this name, Angular knows
where it's located and how to create it.
Since the food finder service will be
in charge of all menu information,
let's move this data to a JSON file and
convert it to proper JSON.
We'll use the food finder
service to fetch this file.
Let's create a get menu function and
use jQuery to fetch the JSON file.
So we've extracted the menu and
set up the service.
Now we just need to hook the service and
the controller together.
The format to inject a service into
a controller looks a little odd.
So let's take it step by step.
First I'll highlight
the entire function,
then I'll copy it and delete it.
To inject something into a controller
we need to pass an array of
things to inject.
So add an array, give the names of
the services we want to inject.
For now it's just a food finder service.
Then pace the controller back in.
The service is now being injected
into the controller as an argument.
To use the service though,
the controller needs to
store it in a variable.
So we'll add a variable
with the name menu here.
To get the menu we need to call
foodfinder's getMenu function.
Since getMenu uses jQuery,
it returns a jQuery deferred
object similar to a promise.
We call then, and when our data gets
returned, we can set it to this items.
Since the this keyword
is contextually based,
this in here isn't
the same as this out here.
We'll just use lexical
scope to fix this.
Typically the variable vm for
view model is used.
And we're still showing
the exact same information.
But now the data is not
tied to this specific view.
There's no limit to the number of
services that can be injected.
Anything that needs to be injected
comes first in the array.
Then the function that's receiving
everything comes at the end, and
has variables for each injected service,
in the same order.